This video is brought to you by a news voice.
The news is broken almost all of the U S media is owned by just a handful of big
corporations. Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something unbiased can be hard.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeed by aggregating major news
sites,
as well as international and independent media giving some much needed balance.
Each news story and shows multiple sources,
which are all tagged with our bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives, what we hear and what we read,
shapes, which people we trust, what we eat, what we buy, how we vote,
and even how we think news voice is created by its readers.
As you can up vote stories that you find interesting.
So more people will see them.
It's essentially a democratized platform from news. Plus it saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources in one app so that you can be better
informed and it's totally free.
So get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's
available on both Google play and the Apple app store.
And our last side of the way let's get into today's video.
[Inaudible].
Thailand is a country capable of attracting Buddhist monks, adventure,
seeking tourists, as well as the teacher mate faint and the hangover part two,
all at the same time,
there are many reasons why we have all heard stories of incredible parties in
Bangkok and not in other places like Brunei or Malaysia reasons like this one.
Thailand leads Asia in legalizing medical marijuana. Next year,
Thailand may become first in Southeast Asia to allow same sex
unions, Japan times.
Oh yes. Beaches, marijuana, LGBT rights, Thailand.
It seems like the Asian version of California,
but with a monarchy and one that is a little bit easier on the wallet. However,
lately Thailand is in the news for headlines like this.
Yes.
The tests and Thailand are making history for the first time in decades.
People are openly defying the authority of the monarchy. Al Jazeera.
Give you an idea of what we're talking about. Since July 20,
20 thousands of Thai people have taken to the streets to ask for a total change
of regime, change the constitution, reform the monarchy and hold free elections,
fun facts instead of raising their Fest or hunt Thai people raise these three
fingers. And yeah, this is straight out of the hunger games. Movie,
trilogy more about that though later,
but let's get back to our story for just now, because trust me,
when I say that Thai people have no shortage of reasons to protest.
We're talking about one of the most authoritarian countries in the world.
[Inaudible].
Thailand's political system is a hybrid between absolute monarchy,
theocracy and military dictatorship sounds fun. Right? In fact,
the Thai Royal house is the richest in the world surpassing even the Petro.
And it has far more power than any European monarchy.
And you're probably thinking, come on, grant, if they're still authoritarian,
how is it possible to have so much tourism? How is it possible?
There are so many digital nomads who go there to live cities like bind Cohn,
and Schine mine are trendy destinations for digital nomads,
which for those who don't know as people who work on lane,
who could live anywhere in the world and who choose to live in Thailand.
And yes, Thailand can be a fantastic country for a westerner.
But if you are tight, you might not think so.
Hi man faces lengthy jail term for sarcastic remark about King's
dog Telegraph.
You give you an idea.
Thailand has the fourth largest prison population in the world,
just behind Turkmenistan Cuba. And of course the United States.
And just a side note here. Yes,
the United States has the largest prison population in the world,
but we've already talked about that here on visual politic before the irony of
the freest country in the world, locking up the most people.
The point is that compared to tight residence,
those in the United States look like five star resorts. And as we'll see later,
it's very easy to end up in a Thai prison.
And all this explains such intense protests as this one.
Thailand protests thousands rally for third straight day,
despite government ban.
However,
none of this news is going to attract much attention and previous visual politic
videos. We have talked about Thai politics.
And if there is one thing that characterizes this country is the regime changes
to give you an idea. Since 1932 Thailand has suffered an average of one Q data.
Every four years, regime changes are so commonplace in this country,
but they don't even make the news anymore. However,
these protests are special and maybe just maybe this time we will
see real regime change, pay attention because today's video has everything,
economics, living, gods and sex, lots of sex,
and even a couple of extra floozy thrown in for good measure.
So the question we're asking today are what makes these protests so significant?
What are the protestors asking for?
What is the real problem in Thailand and why,
why have they adopted the hunger games salute as a form of protest today?
We're going to answer all of these questions,
but first let's take a look at some history.
Design command.
This is not the first time that we've talked about theocracy on visual politic
and many other countries such as Saudi Arabia or Iran,
religion and politics go hand in hand. However,
the case of Thailand goes much further than that.
[Inaudible].
In this case,
the Thai King is considered as the direct representation of God on earth,
pure and simple. In fact,
the current King of Thailand is known as Ramah X ran at a 10th before him,
there was Ramah I X I'm in the ninth.
And so on all the way back to Rama at the first rum as the name given after the
coronation. And it's literally the time name for the goddess Vishal.
[Inaudible].
To give you an idea until 1932 Thailand was an absolute monarchy. Since then,
there has been a constitution that limits the power of the King,
but even so the Monique still has a lot of power. I mean, at the end of the day,
he's a goat.
[Inaudible].
However, divine, they may be tied. Kings are moved by very human passions,
King Rama,
the ninth also known by his first name [inaudible] was chromed when he was 23
years old, after someone murdered his older brother Ramah the eighth night,
this all might sound crazy in and of itself, but wait,
because you haven't seen anything yet,
it would be logical to think that Rama,
the ninth also known as Lord upon our heads or Lord of life was born in
Thailand, right after all he is the King of a country. Well,
that would be a big mistake rather than ninth was born in Cambridge,
Massachusetts later,
his family moved to Switzerland where he studied at the university there.
So let's take a second just here to imagine that situation.
This man who's living in the West is white with his Swiss friends and they asked
him, so where are you going to be when you grew up? And he goes me well,
I'm going to dedicate myself to being a data and Thailand, come on lads.
Let's do some shots.
What's more after so many years of education and the West rather than ninth
acquired certain habits specifically, he learned to play gems
And in fact came to compose his own pieces.
[Inaudible].
Let's get back to our story.
I actually can't imagine if the Thai people consider their King to be a God,
any offense against the monarchy as blossoming or as they call it cranes of
Lamaze yest, because this is not a minor issue. Thailand's Lez,
Majesta laws are known to be very generic. That is,
it is not clear what counts as blasphemy and what does not.
The only thing they are clear about is the penalties,
which can be up to 15 years in prison.
And there are cases that are to put it mildly, totally unreasonable.
All the cases I'm going to give you right now are real examples.
So pay attention.
[Inaudible].
Translating an unauthorized biography of the King two years in prison and
something that King's dog on the internet, 37 years in prison,
serving black paint over a portrait of the King, 10 years in prison.
And hold on because we haven't talked about the cranes of sedition yet,
watch out for the list of things that can land you in jail and Thailand wearing
a red shirt,
eating sandwiches as a form of political protest or showing a piece of paper
that says shooting papers is not a crane. I repeat.
These are all real cases that have put real people and real prisons.
And of course, among these terrible crimes of sedation,
it's this loot from the film, the hunger games.
Apparently.
In 2014, some protestors started to use it.
The gesture caught fire among young people since then raising three fingers like
this is a crane.
No.
Many of you may be wondering how it is possible that the Thai people have not
risen up against their King before the monarchy and Thailand has existed for
centuries after all. Well, the truth is that until a few years ago,
the King of Thailand was a really popular.
Finger.
You have an idea more than 12 million people went to kangaroo and bowls,
funeral to say goodbye to him.
And remember that Thailand has 64 million inhabitants.
That means the on October, the 25th, 2017,
one out of every sex Thai people dropped what they were doing to go to the grand
palace and Bangkok to say goodbye to their go at Cambridge.
[Inaudible].
In cinemas before seeing a movie type,
people have to stand up and listen to the Royal tight Anthem. And no,
I know what you're going to see if the monarchy is so popular in the country,
why do they have so many coups? Well, let's take a look at that.
Right now,
a dictatorship every four years.
One of the main advantages of democracy as that allows for the change of power
without bloodshed,
instead of spending money on weapons for a civil war candidates,
spend it on electoral materials. Well, in the absence of democracy,
the opposite is true in Thailand.
Candidates spend as much on weapons as they do elsewhere on advertising.
[Inaudible].
Thailand has suffered 19 cous since 1930,
two of these 1912 are successful.
And another seven were not all these que de ties follow a similar pattern.
A faction of the army organizes the crew detail.
And it is the King who decides whether he wants to support it or not.
The loser has to go into exile and the winner becomes the country's dictator for
a few years, usually about four. I mean, come on.
They're basically like elections,
but only one person has the vote and that person.
It's the King.
Well, these coups have been really violent. For example, in 1973,
several students demonstrated against the military government of the time.
77 students were massacred and 850 were seriously injured.
The protest.
That same night,
the Kinga knows that the military government had to resign years later,
the dictator Sonoma kittycat Shaun was exiled. However,
other cues were much more peaceful. For example,
the 1957 coup lasted just a few hours. And this case general salaried thinner,
it sent his loyal troops to take over the most important military facilities.
He was supported by a large group of civilians who were protesting in the
streets hours later. This man became silence. New prime minister.
The former leader went into exile in Europe and returned to the country six
years later to become prime minister again. So it seems that in Thailand,
military dictatorships come and go, but thing remains that thing.
It's the monarchy.
And you may be wondering, but how can the people there support less system?
Well, one fairly convincing answer is the economy with,
or without a lack of freedom.
And Thailand is one of the richest countries in the region as a comparison,
the GDP or per capita, and partly with purchasing power is around $18,000.
That of the Philippines is less than half $8,500.
And in China has $17,000.
While many parts of China still do not have modern hospitals.
Thailand has publicly.
Guilty.
Just to give you an idea while their Vietnamese neighbors were coming out of the
famines in the late 1980s,
the ties had the largest automotive and hard drive factories in the region,
not to mention being a real tourist powerhouse in 2018, there were the 10th,
most sophisticated country in the world, far above Japan or Greece.
So how can Thailand have such a relatively developed economy with such a
dreadful political system? Well, mainly for two reasons, it's currency.
The bat is one of the most stable in the world.
And Thailand has always had good relations with the West,
particularly with Japan. So now you'll see. So what's changed no grunt.
Why are these protests so important now? Well, well listen up.
[Inaudible] the middle income trap.
October, 2016,
the beloved leader Kang Ram in the ninth died in hospital at the age of 88
In a country. So dependent on a single person,
the death of the King is attain bomb. But in this case,
the country was on the verge of approving a new constitution through a
referendum. As you can imagine,
it was a referendum where the army told the citizens which way to vote, because,
well,
just because that's what Thailand is like and this case and the absence of a
King,
the military Giunta put a Senate in place and announced free elections and other
words as free as they can be in Thailand,
basically the army would supervise the process,
but at least opposition parties would be able to
What happens when you allow opposition political parties to appear well,
surprise, surprise, new opposition parties,
a marriage for the first time in decades, Thailand's parliament.
How to democratic opposition party with a major presence.
[Inaudible].
We are talking about the future forward party founded by Mr.
[inaudible] [inaudible] John Green Quranic.
It I'd like to apologize formerly here to all the people of Thailand,
although let's be honest. I don't think I'm going there anytime soon. Anyway,
this is a formation that proposes a change in the constitution,
but limits the powers of the King guarantees, free elections and human rights.
And in the March, 2019 elections, they got 18% of the vote,
which is not bad considering that there are more than seven major parties that
make up the parliament. In fact,
future-forward was left with a third of the political power. As you can imagine,
the Lord
it's one of the most influential leaders right now in Thailand.
You, by the way,
the party's leader is also known in Thailand for being the son of one of the
biggest millionaires in the country, far from working against him.
This only reinforced his image,
being able to live a life of luxury and be like worries.
He decided to risk everything to improve the country. And believe me,
the risk is [inaudible].
His party was banned. He faces jail, but Thailand's ton of torn,
drawn groomed rockets, vows to fight on CNN.
The news you've just heard. It could mean the end of the future-forward party.
Nevertheless, many things have changed in Thailand.
The first is the economy.
Remember I told you that Thailand was one of the most prosperous countries in
the region. Well, it's true. It was well,
all the countries of Southeast Asia are growing array of five or six or 7%
Thailand barely exceeds 2% growth in economics. This has a name,
the middle income trap.
[Inaudible].
That is,
there are many countries that managed to escape from poverty and reach what we
call average income. However,
they did not manage to make the leap to being a wealthy country countries like
Brazil, Columbia, and Thailand seem to have stagnated due to this situation.
If you remember,
one of Thailand's main industries is tourism accounts for more than 12% of the
country's GDP. And what is the sector most effected by the Corona virus?
Exactly tourism after tourism.
Another of its main industries in this country as the automotive industry. Well,
check this out.
Generally.
Motors to lay off all 1500 plant workers in Thailand,
following sale of its factories.
We're not just talking about general motors, either triumph.
The motorcycle manufacturers have also closed plants and Thailand,
and many others are threatening to do so
In total car production in Thailand has dropped by 30% in 2020,
and its GDP has fallen by more than 12%.
All of this translates to thousands of people being unemployed. However,
this is not the only thing that has changed in this country.
At the beginning of this video, I promised you sex and Tiera tests.
Yeah.
Confined with 20 concubines.
Yeah. Well,
that's just how the current King of Thailand has spent the confinement and a
mansion in Germany with 20 concubines. And I know what some of you will say,
how do you know the all 20 of these women were concubines? Well,
if they were just as servants or even as friends, well,
the truth is that King [inaudible] has had a long and well known relationship
with the concubines.
Ty Playboy King annoyance lover as his official concubine. The times.
I would say that they have a collaborator or a special friend, but in Thailand,
they call things by their name, the official concubine. It's as simple as that,
there are even videos on WikiLeaks where you can see, you can see a lot.
In fact, you can see everything about this King, of course, on visual politic.
We're not interested in judging everyone's sex life.
As long as he isn't breaking any laws,
this man can do whatever he wants and believe us. He does not remember that.
He's not just a kangaroo. He is also around the 10th.
Nothing less than a gun.
You see during his reign,
the previous King Rehmann the ninth had earned the respect of the Thai people
and in such a conservative society, ramen,
the ninth represented righteousness and discipline.
His son is just the opposite. He's been divorced.
Three times has four illegitimate children and has appointed his dog as
commander of the air force. If all of this were not enough King Rama,
the 10th does not even live in Thailand. In 2016,
he bought a mansion in Bavaria,
in Southern Germany and wants to reel Thailand from there. Yeah.
In fact, this is one of his conditions for approving the 2017 constitution.
They had to let him reign from Germany. And I know what you're thinking now.
What if this can simply doesn't want to reign? I mean, that could be the case.
He wants to get away from politics. I love his own life,
but the reality is quite the opposite.
Two weeks ago,
the Thai King issued a Royal decree placing two army units under his direct
control rather than under the normal military hierarchy world politics review.
That's right,
rather than the 10th is taking steps to restore the absolute monarchy in
Thailand. He's gaining more and more control over the army.
And the 2019 elections. He banned his sister from running from prime minister.
And that's not the worst thing you see until 2017,
the assets of the Thai Royal house were managed by the Chrome property Bureau
and institution controlled by the ministry.
Finance.
To give you an idea,
these assets comprise something like a sovereign fund with investments and local
companies. For example,
the tie Royals are the main shareholders of one of the largest banks in the
country, the Siam commercial bank. Well,
the first thing that rounded the tempted as soon as he came to ruin was to take
full control of this office.
It is estimated that the institution controls $40 billion that are now solely in
the hands of the King. And it doesn't end there. In addition to that,
his salary has been raised for 2021.
The Royal Thai house will receive more than $1.1 billion from the government and
all this for ruling from his mentioned in Germany.
[Inaudible].
Other words,
Thailand has all the ingredients for a properly revolt economic malaise,
a corrupt elite that has lost the trust of the majority of assistants and the
leader Mr.
[Inaudible] capable.
Of bringing together all of this discontent.
And what might you wonder are these protestors asking for their main demands are
to put an end to crimes against the Royal leader to force the crime,
to be transparent with its assets and to prohibit the King from instigating QD
times, these might seem like very moderate claims,
but remember that we are talking about what is perhaps the most monarchial
country in the world.
And that's why it's so incredible that it's only now that we're starting to hear
things.
[Inaudible].
Call for end of monarchy on King's birthday, Deutsche Avaya.
Right? But we are not talking about just one or two protests.
The demonstrations in Thailand began in February,
2020 and the King's birthday was the end of July in July 20,
20 many more people started to take to the streets and squares and universities
there have been protests and all of the main cities.
So far there have been no deaths,
but there have been several attempts by the army and the police to suppress the
person.
[Inaudible].
The demonstrators continued to protest. So now the question is over to you.
Do you think that these protests will create real change in Thailand?
What do you think of the time monarchy and of monarchies in general?
Do you think it's an outdated institution or perhaps one that still has a place
in our tank and will I ever get to go to Thailand,
leave your answers in the comments below as always.
We really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit the Lake if you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that we're not my dulcet tones.
Finally,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see in the next video.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play,
or your favorite pod catcher.